hey I'm dr. Keller and we all know that  one of the best ways to cure a hangover  is preventing it in the first place and  that's why you have to pretreat I'm  talking about just eating something  before you start your whole night of  binge drinking basically having some  food in the stomach is going to slow  down the absorption of the alcohol that  you're consuming more or less twenty  percent of alcohol is absorbed in the  stomach but the other eighty percent is  in the small intestine if you have food  in your stomach it's going to slow down  the alcohols arrival to the small  intestine and you'll have more time to  enjoy a slow steady rise of a buzz  instead of a rush I'm dr. Keller and  there's a hangover prevention tip for  you